eu fui assistir Anabelle dois não
satisfeito em ter assistido um aí beleza
Fui lá assisti Anabelle e tal e o Silvio
Santos fez a pegadinha da Anabelle assim
a pessoa né a pessoa da normal da rua
pessoa que eu digo não é ator vai cuidar
da criança na casa e aí a boneca lá vira
o satanás e os Caral E aí eu vi essa
pegadinha do Silvio Santos antes de
assistir o filme só que eu fiquei
Assombrado com essa pegadinha Eu fiquei
todo lugar que eu entro agora eu penso
que tá tendo uma pegadinha do Silvio
Santos eu entro numa casa que tem uma
criança Silvio Santo ent no supermercado
de madrugada Silvio Santo Ô Silvio Santo
ou no restaurante comida tá boa Silvio
que foi que saiu também a menina que
assistiu annabella em Teresina ficou
surtada vocês viram esse vídeo a menina
assistiu annabella lá no cinema de
Teresina não sei se misturou com calor
també mesm porque à vez Satanás faz as
compras no Teresina Shopping que é onde
o clima para ele é mais gostoso você tá
assim fazendo umas compras Só sei que a
menina depois que assistiu Anabelle
surtou Ficou rodando no chão lá do
shopping rodando o povo olhando as
pessoas falando meu Deus Olha a menina
possuído vamos filmar colocar na
internet